I'm very excited to announce that Megan
and myself had a baby boy early this
morning a very healthy boy Prince
Harry's been the epitome of proud papa
since the day he announced
Archie's birth last May this little
thing is absolute fool so I'm just when
he and wife Megan Markel introduced us
to their son Madrid it was an overjoyed
Harry who gave us our first peek because
the sweetest temperament he's really
well based on the sounds of it Archie
got his temperament from Papa Harry who
was cool as a cucumber when asked how he
was adjusting to Parenthood yeah that's
great parenting is amazing this it's
only being what two and a half days
three days
but we just were just so thrilled to
have our own little bundle of joy we
have to spend some precious time as I
them as I study slowly starts to grow up
the next day Harry accepted gifts for
his mini-me while launching the Invictus
games in The Hague Netherlands
even attempted to try one of the
presents on
but let's be honest Harry's custom I am
daddy pull over it was a much better fit
[Applause]
the gifts kept coming when the new
parents met with the Boston Red Sox and
the New York Yankees ahead of their
first game in London last June we want
to congratulate you according to Harry
the Yanks wept more than the two-game
series in July the first time dad
honored his late mom while speaking at
the National Youth mentoring summit
created in her honor my mother Princess
Diana was a role model to so many
without realizing the impact she had she
would have on so many lives he also
snuck in a few sweet words about setting
a positive example for his young son I'm
struck by a few things today most of
which is the power of the invisible role
model you inspire them to be kind of
better greater more successful impactful
perhaps it's the newfound Authority I
have as a father knowing that my son
will always be watching what I do
mimicking my behavior one day maybe even
following in my footsteps but Harry's
cute dad vibes were off the charts
during the Sussex is trip to Africa I
wanted to ensure that our first visit as
a family with my wife by my side focused
on the significant challenges facing
millions of South Africans while
acknowledging the hope that we feel so
strongly here when he wasn't busy giving
Archie shoutouts as I raised my hand son
I want to make sure that what I've
learned here the value of the natural
world the value of community and
friendship is something that I can pass
on to him I always protect my family and
now I have a family to protect
[Music]
the Papa was introducing his then
four-month-old son to prominent figures
like Nobel Peace Prize winner Archbishop
Desmond Tutu every reference Harry made
to his son
totally tugged at our heartstrings it's
about redefining masculinity it's about
creating your own footprints for your
children to following so that you can
make a positive change for the future
and just when you thought Harry couldn't
get any sweeter it has been over a
decade since I first came to these
awards and every year they never failed
to surprise and inspire me yet this year
it resonates in a different way because
now I'm a father our favorite ginger
brought us all to tears with his speech
at the well-child Awards last October
last year last year when my wife and I
attended we knew we were expecting our
first child no one else did at the time
but we did and I remember
and I remember squeezing Megan's hands
so tight during the awards and both of
us were thinking what it would be like
to be parents one day and more so what
it would be like to do everything we
could to protect and help our child
should they be born with immediate
challenges or become unwell over time
few the tissues now as parents being
here and speaking to all of you pulls at
my heartstrings in a way I could never
have understood it until I had a child
of my own speaking the fellow parents
really seems to bring out the softer
side of Harry I can't even begin to much
know you guys having one kid respect to
every single one of you that's the Duke
opening up about the struggles of
parenting while video chatting with
families helped by the well-child
organization Harry also dished on how
he's been passing the time during
quarantine amid the global coronavirus
pandemic there's a hell of a lot of
positives to that that are happening at
the same time in being able to have
family time you've got to celebrate
those moments where you just are on the
floor rolling around in hysterics
because of something that's happening
and then inevitably an hour later and
your day later there's gonna be
something that you have to deal with and
there's no way that you can run away
and here's another milestone Harry
opened up about back in January it has
also been a privilege to feel your
excitement for our son watching who saw
snow for the first time the other day
that thought he was bloody brilliant
but nothing beats this sweet father-son
moment the Sussex is shared on Instagram
at new years or the video they posted in
honor of arches first birthday
robo not rabbit we stand this adorable
family happy Father's Day to Harry and
all the dads out there and that's what
really matters to us
[Music]